ladies and gentlemen straight from set
in Toronto Canada where he's been
wrangling the most unruly group of super
villains ever put to celluloid please
give a huge Comicon welcome to director
David Ayer
Thank You Asia for having us we were
just shooting last night in Toronto but
we had to come down because we had to
come in and report it in the hall H
because you guys run this [ __ ] okay
we're making this movie for you okay
this DC Comics [ __ ] right here it's all
about cannon it's all about being
faithful to the source material you guys
know who you are and you know what you
want you're gonna freakin get it with
this show okay and all this you know
good versus evil shit's kind of played
out right now it's time for bad versus
evil right it's about time for a movie
about bad guys and who's got the best
bad guys out there DC Comics best
villains ever now I'm not trying to
start no you know East Coast West code
feud with Marvel Comics now but hey
someone's got to say the truth all right
now I got a little little footage I want
to show you guys we've been working
really hard and fortunately a lot of
people with iPhones have been running
around grabbing it so it's a little
something I found on the internet that
I'd like to show you you guys want to
meet the cast
all right let me get them out here
presenting katana character the horror
Slipknot out of Beach
enchantress card olivine Diablo
journalist
gillich rock on Wally budget
Deb coumarine exact coordinating Colonel
Rick Flagg Joe get in watch out for this
next one amanda waller Viola Davis
Harley Quinn margot robbie and the man
who cannot miss Will Smith Deadshot
all right that's not a bit thanks for
having us guys we got to go back to work
want to say something hey listen the
Suicide Squad we've been in Toronto this
group right here we are bringing out
something that is absolutely fantastic
and and stunning and this guy right here
David Ayer is the absolute truth he is
making something you I brought of love
David Ayer you'll see what's inside
thank you thank you
are you kidding me
I'm sorry I really was back there having
a picture I'm so sorry okay oh lordy I
might have peed myself just a tiny bit
all right you guys I am super excited I
know somebody out there has some
unnatural love for the person that's
about to come out on this stage but it
can't be SD intense or unnatural as mine
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage Zack Snyder
okay so first of all exactly is not your
first comic-con
you're a pro so welcome back to Hall H
and this is a very special movie I want
to know a little bit quickly about how
stoked you are you always been a comic
book enthusiast you've lived in this
world for a while now how insane is this
particular film for you well it's cool
because I mean for me you know it's
really a dream come true type a project
because I've always been into the sort
of big icon superheroes and Batman and
Superman I mean I don't know
after that what do you do yeah it's uh
they're pretty it's pretty epic
yeah it's and by the way and getting a
chance to make this particular movie
with with this particular cast it's
minoo for me how it gets any any better
than that
yeah I really honestly it's it's been a
pleasure and an honor working with this
this group it's it's and I've seen some
footage of helmets extraordinary I don't
I don't know quite how articulate what
an epic what an epic collision and story
this is going to be I think the thing to
do right now is to bring the rest of the
cast of analogy do it yeah okay so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage Holly Hunter
water running herself go
the sinister Jesse Eisenberg
sinister he's super sinister look at him
he's got a blazer on this evil ladies
and gentlemen Amy
out of the one suit and into another
back on our stage Henry Cavill
and ladies and gentlemen the Batman
Oh Jeremy do we not have Jeremy oh he is
here he wasn't oh well ladies and
gentlemen Jeremy Irons wonderful our
team is fully assembled okay so I think
before we chat there's something that as
a quants to show everybody
oh yeah well all right so we put this
together especially for you guys it's um
it's a not not the whole movie of course
but uh I think you get a little bit of a
taste of what it's about I've got two
big questions off the top before I move
to the audience and the first one is for
people here who are not DC experts not
everybody has read every DC book three
people in the back who've never slept
how canonical is this conflict how
rooted in Canon is the Batman V Superman
conflict or is this something that was
created for this film because personally
I never heard of it till now well it I
mean listen you know the if you want to
talk about the story itself or about the
the the sort of particulars of this
movie that was the thing that we it's
definitely based on just ideas that we
had you know in a room talking about
like what would be cool to see now the
idea of Batman fighting Superman is not
is not a it's a it's a thing that
happens all the time in the comic books
it's but you know for me images like
there's a bunch of images and there's
been a lot of talk about my sort of love
of a particular comic book which is but
you know the Dark Knight Returns which
is you know
a comic book that I love and I I
definitely omage a lot in the movie as a
way of saying to Frank Miller like your
genius and I think that book is genius
but the story itself is not that story
the story itself is a story that we came
up with just you know on our own Chris
Terrio who's the amazing writer of the
the screenplay
you know as a genius who you work with
been on Argo and did an amazing job and
that movie is great and you know he and
he you know he's he's you know he and I
just you know we just talked about like
what how do you make this make sense
like what is the lie of Batman fighting
Superman and there's a lot of we had a
lot of great we had done stuff in Man of
Steel that actually allowed us to create
a conflict that really makes sense for
what this movies about and also sort of
launch you toward what could be bigger
conflicts with maybe more more other
superheroes home who knows I mean I
don't I mean I do know I totally know
you're a comic tease yeah oh yeah thank
you thank you I'm glad you worked
through that with me because my song is
um this is also the first time we're
seeing Batman and Superman together on
the big screen I've seen it in the books
before obviously many times and it's
also the first time we both have we have
both Gotham and metropolis together so
again how did you merge those universes
and kind of what rules did you follow
and what rules did you break yeah well I
mean I think the rule that with the big
rule that we broke is we put Gotham and
metropolis right next to each other I
don't know if it appeared that way ever
maybe somewhere probably it's been you
know if you dig deep enough you can find
a justification for just about
everything but it made sense to us and
work for our story that they were kind
of sister cities you know across a big
bay and so you had kind of it's like
Oakland and San Francisco kind of yeah
I'm from San Francisco San Francisco
would win I think okay you're from
metropolis I'm from metropolis okay that
feels good we look people know this
world they think they know this world
intimately but there have been so many
iterations and so many reboots obviously
in the DC Universe I want to talk a
little bit about the panel here because
this is a pretty iconic group of
characters that people know that have
been played before if we could just go
down the line and talk a little bit
about what creative challenge that
presents when you're playing a character
that's been played before multiple times
by multiple actors what do you again
what do you stay true to from the Canon
and what do you invent and was that
challenging for you did everybody just
find a new way into the character and
it's simple I don't know shall we start
with me start with anyone who would like
to start this is a democracy okay
well Michael Caine was pretty amazing as
Alfred so I had big shoes to sit in but
he's a little different my Alfred so I
think there are surprises in store but I
along myself on the explosions around me
and on the world around me I followed
the boss and tried to make him happy and
tried to make him safe and try to make
him grow up a little hi everyone you
look so beautiful thank you for being
here I'm so excited so I'm just buying
some time well for me with Wonder Woman
I feel like I have been given such a
huge opportunity to show the strong
beautiful side of women finally
thank you and Wonder Woman has all the
strength of a superhero but at the same
time at the same time she's very
sophisticated loving and has a lot of
emotional intelligence so for me I feel
very very privileged to be the one who's
going to bring her back to life and I
just can't wait to celebrate this
character and I hope you all enjoy it I
was gonna say the thing about the strong
independent women but she took know my
character has been in obviously other
movies and you know there's always kind
of like I can't be element to the
character but probably in terms of your
question I think there's probably a real
kind of emotional groundedness to this
version of it and I tribute that to the
writer Chris Terrio his exit was just
such a phenomenal writer and it gives
every character in this movies like real
emotional core even though the
situations are so heightened and
theatrical mm-hmm yes it's also he had
also had the most luxurious locks of any
Luthor never really very I mean swing
that around that was beautiful a very
low bar they were all both it's great
I've never been to comic-con I just
realized you guys are you guys are
awesome and a lot of energy I like um
Lois Lane uh I wanted to be Lois Lane
since I was five years old so there we
go and I watched I think it was Superman
to on repaid over and over and over um
but when the when the opportunity rose
of course I was nervous I wanted to you
know make you guys all happy with Lois
but at the same time I was just willing
and open to sort of bring a very modern
take on her and and and just sort of
embrace again this really strong woman
and and it's it's this wonderful thing
that women have where we have this
emotional intelligence and and
vulnerability along with strength that I
thought was really beautiful that Zack
lets me bring to Lois for me well
obviously especially Tresor Eve did such
a fantastic job I was a whose it was a
dangerous for me to go anywhere near
that so I left that to its own thing and
then just with Zack on Man of Steel
built the character as much as I could
drawing from the Canon and I've just
tried to follow that and stay true to
the character that we we ran with the
Man of Steel
I think if I if I thought too hard about
the actors who played this part before I
couldn't have taken the job I mean Tim
Burton Val Kilmer George Clooney the
great Christian Bale and I I talked to
sac about I was like are you sure you
know and he said I have this vision I
had this idea for the guy and you're
perfect for it as well what do you mean
he's like to get the end of his rope
he's older he's like a burnout but
instrument thank you
thanks mom yeah the the truth was that
he took me through the process of
creating this character that I quite
almost didn't see and at the end of it I
was like even sort of astonished to look
at and go that's exactly what you
pitched me and I wasn't even sure I was
I was doing it I had this really weird
experience where before we started the
movie I was getting my kid Halloween
costume and my son is really into Batman
and why is Lee and he we went to a store
a costume store in Los Angeles and it's
pretty empty and I was in the aisle and
I hear this voice and I turn around its
Christian Bale who was the sweetest guy
and there he and I are standing in the
Batman comic and I said look man you
know you're the best like what do you
think you got any tips and make sure you
can piss in that suit
these are practical concerns yeah we put
a zipper on it yeah did you actually I
think Henry we put a zipper on this your
suit retro actively didn't we this time
yeah this time yeah here you don't think
of these things it's I think you'll be
fine I mean how long is it gonna be like
50 now is them hold on let me just say
let me just say holly has an original
part in the film and I've been such a
giant fan of Holly's forever when we
were writing the script yeah I was like
okay we need to find a pup
I need we need to write a part for holly
hunter to play in this movie I don't
care what the app it is but it turns out
that it's in a super important part so
that's that's good but she's amazing I'm
gonna I'm gonna do that I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be a dick uh because you know the
the title begs a very specific question
right which part of the title Batman V
Superman title very good uh and you know
you've heard this a million times since
you started developing this film when
you'll hear two million times after who
would win a fight between Batman and
Superman
now I'm not gonna ask that question
because I made a whole movie about yeah
that's good for today and then you know
because again essential to this conflict
is an amour you know an immortal man you
know a God as you articulated in the
film versus a human being which begs a
lot of other questions about kind of you
know us embracing our own humanity and
what that means
however this Batman seems to be mecha
Batman he is a little bit augmented
Batman big the thing to look at in the
we call it the mech suit whatever but it
really in truth it's not it's a
self-preservation concept not to you
know give anything away but it's not
really enhancing his strength more than
protecting him buying him time if you
will from everything that Superman is
going to a lot of his eyeballs almost
like a pinata
you know so it's it's right you have to
see because it's slightly complicated
okay
we're gonna we're gonna use it as a
whole movie literally that's the only
question yeah hi um okay and so uh you
are adorable look at you yes thank you
strike a pose anyway clearly in the
movie you do with a lot of philosophical
issue who's in the film and what I was
wondering is if any of what you walk
through maybe perhaps change the way
that you will look at life now you just
stayed adorable through the entire
question who's it for your ability
whoever has an answer for it on the sack
you can take this one is there anybody
who wants to tackle that was like those
guys down at that end that seems like
that Superman I just I don't know it's
kind of tough for me to say I play a god
so I'm gonna step away from this I think
there are some really interesting that
Zack and Chris put together some really
interesting ideas of you know metropolis
being a big successful city in Gotham
City being a place where a lot more
downtrodden people live and there's a
fairy they take across the people who
work in Metropolis take from Gotham City
and the whole idea of you know wealth
and power and the way power and genders
fear and there were a lot of really
ideas that were a little bit too smart
for me to understand but that the movie
was trafficking in and that I thought
made it feel real to me and and smart
and so I was even more proud to be part
of it this is from someone who made a
movie that I had to I had to go to
Wikipedia every five minutes to
understand Argo but sure yeah Superman
vs Batman too smart for Ben Affleck okay
sure I'll get more Wikipedia when we're
all Superman's back out of the gym again
was it leg day or arm day all right
let's go to look at this guy's
look at this guy's tattoos yeah he's got
tattoos on his calves
oh very super man ah how do I know that
I've seen him before you know what back
so have we go for it buddy when you guys
were filming the movie at what point in
time did you say oh my god we're coming
up with something great awesome we're
gonna blow all your God says minds away
without spoilers but if you do or
spoilers please thank you while shooting
the movie
I feel like yes I mean you know like the
truth is I mean when you're shooting a
movie there are moments when you shoot
the movie that feel like wow this is
cool I mean just for instance when
actually when we were doing it look we
did a little photo shoot
you know while everyone's getting their
costumes together and it's like Wonder
Woman and Superman and Batman all sort
of standing there getting their pictures
taken you're like oh my lord that's
crazy
okay but I think that you know for me it
was it actually happens long before that
you know when we're just kind of
figuring out what we're gonna do and I'm
drawing and we're just kind of doing
ideas of you know different kind of
images that we're gonna create and I
just normally this is gonna sound weird
but I'm by myself when that's happening
and I don't do anything weird but it is
there is that moment like when you do
like if you do a doodle and you're like
oh my lord I know that that's I want to
see that I wanna I wanna let's wear the
cameras we need to get where is
everybody come on let's go shoot this so
I think that that that's really for me
the moment I don't know like for these
guys if they had different experiences
of course they probably would but you
know because by the time also I'm
filming I've seen the costume a thousand
times and you know it's it's like a love
scene you know there's everyone talks
about oh and you do a love scene is it
sexy you know I don't know because I've
never done a love scene in a movie I've
only witnessed it that would be weird
may we say the actors are always like
yeah now it's like this
so I don't know if they have that same
feeling when they're in their superhero
costumes I had a feeling where you know
I am
first of all wants a Christian Bale's
also buying his son a suit he doesn't
just hang out but for me you know like
you look at the cast and you look at the
script and that's so much of what's
there and I always thought you can only
tweak a certain amount past that because
you've almost kind of made the movie and
I remember a day about two weeks in it
where I read the scene and I thought
about how to play it and I came in and
watched it and I thought okay yeah we
should probably like shoot it this way
or that way and Zach set the shot up so
that it was one shot and he put it on a
crane and it came around and it covered
everybody's dialogue and it kind of
encompassed the scope of what we want to
do and I was just like [ __ ] I would
never do that that's so good
sorry it says people are under 18
they've heard it before
but anyway that's I remember thinking
that we were in good hands before we
before we move towards the end we just
haven't heard anything from Holly and I
just want to hear something out of your
beautiful mouth with your beautiful
voice all right well I'll be able wind
we have one last what kind of thing you
want to do for the audience before we go
and are we gonna take another I guess we
should take one more look at the piece
cuz I know it's it goes by fast guys
this happened to all of us today as a
team wrap it up in a warm little ball
stick it deep inside this has been
amazing Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice opens March 25th 2016 please
give it up for Holly Hunter Jeremy Irons
golga yo Jesse Eisenberg Amy Adam
Henry Cavill Ben Affleck and your
fearless leader mr. Zack Snyder go and
kick ass peppy card
you